[Music]
well here we are I turn down here at the
next block thanks mister I'll get off
there
Wacka thing l know me
you wait ahead
nice event I love you was heading north
I might be able to help you out pushing
this all lake and I don't like the ride
alone at night I'm one of those guys who
got a talker I fall asleep
a party he's got blue to keep him
company but I ain't got nobody at all
where you coming from
waste surely nobody where LA maybe my
cousin out in LA
you don't say yeah he's gonna do you're
not much of a talker right my mother
taught me never to speak to strangers oh
why so okay okay don't get so uh trying
to be sociable that's all
hey glamorous we change for a dime with
you let's have something quieter this
time Joe my head's splitting that what's
wrong with it done with your coffee no
and don't rush me will you
[Music]
hey turn that off you turn that thing
off what you know
yeah what's eatin you that music it
stinks oh you don't like it huh no trade
off wait a minute pal that was my name
see this is a free country
I play whatever I wanted
[Music]
sure if you don't like it you don't have
to listen to it and you can leave here
anytime you wanna okay okay I'm sorry I
asked
first good piece play tonight you don't
like it some people just ain't got any
good taste
[Music]
time I was there always that rotten -
that one way around beating in my head
never letting up did you I don't want to
forget anything did you ever want to cut
away a PC of memory of bled out you
can't you know no matter how hard you
try you can change the scenery but
sooner or later you'll get a whiff of
perfume where somebody will say a
certain phrase or maybe hum something
then you're licked again I can't believe
that you're in love with me I used to
love that song once so did the customers
back in the old break of dawn Club in
New York I can't remember a night when I
didn't get at least three requests for
it sue
she was always selling it - those were
the days
[Music]
your eyes are blue your kisses - I never
knew what they could do I can't believe
that you're in love with me that I'm on
your mind each place you go they can't
believe that you're in love with me
[Music]
I just can't imagine that me and after
all this send them to think that I'm the
lucky one I can't believe that you in
love with me
[Music]
[Applause]
it wasn't much of a club really you know
the kind a joint where you could have a
sandwich and a few drinks and run
interference for your girl on the dance
floor
I founded the piano in there every night
from 8:00 until a place closed up which
usually meant 4:00 in the morning a good
job as jobs went in those days
[Music]
and two there was sue who made working
there a little like working in heaven
but how we felt about each other well
there was nothing very unusual in that I
was an ordinary healthy guy and she was
an ordinary healthy girl and when you
add those two together you get an
ordinary healthy romance which is the
old story
sure but somehow the most wonderful
thing in the world
[Music]
all in all I was a pretty lucky guy
[Music]
mr. paderewski I presume it's beautiful
you're going to make Carnegie Hall yet
out yeah as a janitor I'll make my debut
in the basement I don't blame you for
being better darling but you mustn't
give up hope
why someday yeah someday but don't get
arthritis first the meantime let's blow
this trap
[Music]
like to get some DEET hon I don't think
so well I lose my appetite working in
this fleabag
let's go home okay I can't stand much
more of that dump did you see that drunk
tonight trying to Paul me know what
drunk does it matter what drunk hey
what's the matter with you tonight
darling that's the third time he started
to tell me something then stop we
shouldn't have any secrets from each
other soon next week we're gonna make
with the ring and the license you and me
will be a team yes that's right in the
bush league I don't get you
we've been struck out it's a funny way
to talk darling what you want to marry
me look I love you you know I do and I
want to marry you but but not now only
after we've made it good Sunday I'm
going away
I know you'll think it's silly that's
why I hesitated to tell you but I'm
going to California I want to try my
luck in Hollywood that's the most stupid
thing I ever heard of
don't you know millions of people go out
there every year and wind up publishing
cuspidors I thought you had better sense
you sound as if you don't think I have
any Talent that has nothing to do with
it I'll make out alright maybe but what
about me doesn't it mean anything to you
that you're busting up all our plans we
may not see each other for years it
won't be that long I thought you loved
me
I do you know I do
there we are Oh oh why can't you see my
side of it I'm young
we both are and we've got all the time
in the world to settle down really
darling what I'm doing is the only sane
thing to do I I hate the thought of
being so far away from you but but we'll
be together again someday maybe you'll
decide to come out too later on so long
aren't you going to kiss me goodnight
sure
[Music]
[Applause]
say Robert you hit the jackpot this time
ten bucks thanks
[Applause]
so when this drunk handed me a 10-spot
after a request I couldn't get very
excited but was it I asked myself
he's a paper crawling with germs
couldn't buy anything I wanted it
couldn't
[Music]
and I thought of something
[Music]
[Music]
long distance I like to put a call to
the Los Angeles miss Harvey sue Harvey
har Bui the number is Crestview six five
seven two three
[Music]
hello sue this is al Oh baby it's great
to hear from you too
what's that you do oh me too darlin I
thought I'd go batty without you I just
had to huh
you're working as a hash slinger see
honey that's tough those guys out in
Hollywood don't know the real thing when
it's right in front of them you just
stick it out sue baby keep going around
those casting offices
I'm sure you'll click there I'll come to
you no don't try to stop me just expect
me train who know is trained plane bus
magic-carpet I'll be there if I have to
crawl have to travel by pogo stick and
then let's get married right away huh
that's the stuff that's what I've been
wanting to hear you say well goodbye for
now I'll be seeing you soon yeah
way I could cross country with the thumb
rides or even after Hawking everything I
only had enough money to eat money you
know what that is
it's a stuff you never have enough of
little green things with George
Washington's picture that men slaved for
commit crimes for die for
it's a stuff that has caused more
trouble in the world and anything else
we ever invented simply because there's
too little of it at least I had too
little of it so it was me for the phone
[Music]
ever done any hitchhiking it's not much
fun believe me oh yeah I know all about
how it's an education and how you get to
meet a lot of people and all that but me
from now on I'll take my education in
college or in PS 62 or I'll send a
dollar 98 and stamps for 10 easy lessons
[Music]
thumbing rides may save you bus fare but
it's dangerous you never know what's in
store for you hear the squeal of brakes
if only I had known what I was getting
into that day in Arizona backseat
okay let's go make sure that Doris
[Music]
you know Emily Post oughta write a book
of rules for guys thumbing rides because
as it is now you never know what's right
and what's wrong
he wrote along for a little while
neither one of us saying anything
I never know what to say to strange
people driving cars and - you could
never tell if a guy wants to talk a lot
of rides have been cut short because of
a big mouth so I kept my mouth shut
until he started opening up a me that
little box to comply with it pal
all the whale with
I'll fire you gone la wow you're really
traveling aren't you yeah but I don't
expect to make it for a couple of years
at the rate I've been forwarding rights
not much like that
sure all bad how many people stopped for
a guy these days afraid of a stick-up
maybe they can't blame him well yeah
coming from New York well New York there
in left this time I'm going all the way
right through to Los Angeles goodbye the
car sure maybe attire let me know I'll
holla I guess at least an hour passed
before I notice those deep scratches
right hand they will wicked free puffy
red lines about a quarter of an inch
apart
they must have seen me looking at them
because he said beauties aren't they
they're gonna be scarred someday what an
animal whatever it was it must have been
pretty big and vicious to have done that
I don't both Casa New York I was
hustling with the most dangerous animal
in the world a woman this must have been
Tarzan's maid looks like you lost about
certainly wasn't a draw you know there
oughta be a lord get some games with
flaws yeah I talked her out of the car
and I read that wrong
give her left or Tamara expected to be
nice don't you yeah after all what kind
of a dame some rides Sunday School
teachers a little witch supposed I
thought she was riding with some fall
guy
Emilio's when Booker horses around
racetrack since I was 20
not a million things like her to meet
him yeah
stop the car open the door they get
nothing Arthur Duffy sister I told her
as that was done on but if you want to
see a real scar brother get a load of
this well I got that one Joey Julie yeah
we're just kidding of course my dad
owned a couple of franco-prussian Sabres
kept him on the wall for decorations now
one day and the kid night took him down
the old man wasn't around at a door get
me in the arm here pretty mean cut
section set in lady yeah I can see that
I'll give me that box again with it yeah
Payne made me lose my head I guess I
began slashing before I know it I put
the other kids aiya
that was tough well it was just an
accident of course do you know how kids
are
I got scared decided I was gonna run
away from home oh man almost caught me
when I was packing my debts
the bloody rag I had wrapped around my
wrist hadn't caught his attention just
seemed a bundle for sure
but I beat it when he was falling for
adopted I was 1516 years ago I haven't
been home since
well in that for a bite of something huh
a bite us
brother was i hungry I hadn't had
anything in my stomach for hours
yet even with that gnawing in the foot
of my belly I didn't want to be in too
big a rush to put on the feedbag first I
had to make sure this guy knew the score
I got him down on me goodbye ticket to
Hollywood I'll wait out here for you
mister well there's the money don't
worry about paying for it this time it's
on me
well that's what Haskell like nothing of
it you make your first million maybe you
can do the same for me come on New York
I gotta make the West Coast by Wednesday
the horse running it's Santa Anita named
tired bicycle means daughter me of my
money you'll make it all right he did
most of the talking during the half hour
we were in the place I ate he rambled on
about his old man whom he hadn't heard
from since he ran away as a kid now we
happen to become a bookie and then all
about how he got rooked in Miami one
race 38 grand they cleaned out my book
how do you like that that was tough luck
yeah and I'm supposed to be the smart
guy will you just wait I'm going back to
Florida next season with all kinds of
check you watch those stinkers run for
cover boy anything else no thanks I've
had plenty
their sister oh just a miniature changed
their game insisted oh thank you say
call again we waiting outside for when
you finish work job together
[Music]
I drove all that night while Hesco slept
like a log after a while I began to get
sleepy myself I was happy though soon
I'd be with Sue again the long trip was
practically over and had been no more
hooking at down the concrete
I began to think of the future
which couldn't have been brighter if I'd
embroidered it with neon lights it was
nice to think of sue shooting to the top
it's amazing what a full belly can do to
your imagination
Oh your kisses do I never knew in love
with me
[Music]
everyone
I'm on your mind
[Music]
I can't believe that we were in law
[Music]
[Music]
mr. Haskell mr. Haskell
mr. Haskell wake up it's raining don't
you think we got to stop and put up the
top
[Music]
we start haskell i'm going to put up the
top
[Music]
until then I had done things my way but
from then on something else stepped in
and shunted me off to a different
destination the one I had to pick for
myself the one I pulled open that door
mr. Haskell what's the matter are you
hurt are you hurt mr. Haskell start
yourself I'll listen to it I know what
you're gonna hand me even before you
open your mouth you're gonna tell me you
don't believe my story about Haskell
died and give me that don't make me
laugh expression on your smug faces I
saw it once he was dead and I was in for
it who would believe he fell out of the
car
why if Haskell came to which of course
he couldn't even he would swear i conked
him over the head for his dog yes I was
in for it instinct told me to run but
then I realized it was hopeless there
were lots of people back down the road
who could identify me that gas station
guy and the way keys
it would be in a worse spot then trying
to explain why I beat it the next
possibility was to sit tight and tell
the truth from the cops scheme but that
would be crazy
they'd laugh at the truth not having my
head in the noose
so what else was it to do but hide the
body and get away in the car I couldn't
leave the car there with him in the
gully that would be like a wrecking a
tombstone
[Music]
my idea was to cover him with brush not
to Robin but then I remember that even
if I only drove the car for 100 miles or
so I would need money for gas besides it
was stupid of me to leave all that money
in a dead man
not only that I'd have to take his
driver's license in case I was stopped
for something I didn't like to think
about it but by that time I'd done just
what the police would say I did even if
I didn't I closed the owner of such an
expensive car would never be wearing
them some cop might put me in a
suspicion
[Music]
hey you this your car don't you know
better to leave a car without wheels
halfway in the middle of the road that's
the way accidents happened I'm I'm sorry
officer I was just putting up my top I
didn't think well the next time think
I'll let you go now but watch your step
in the future I know that's a lonely
stretch but cars can buy her once in a
while we have plenty of crack codes
Thanks
I have nothing in the car to give me
away as Robinson
they found a dead man on the gully
novelist it would be me
[Music]
as I drove off it was still raining and
the drop streak down the windshield like
tears
I kept imagining I was being followed
but I could hear sirens back in the
distance just how long it took me to
cover the 60 odd miles to the California
State Line I don't know I lost all track
of time but the rain had stopped and the
Sun was up when I pulled up to the
inspection station
very many fruits and vegetables any
livestock or poultry I see your
registration and driver's license please
anything in the baggage compartment miss
Peggy Charles Haskell June 8 30 brown
eyes dark haired down a fine marks none
are you child Haskell jr. yes well
remember if you employed in your stay
over 30 days you take out California
plates alright officer but I'll only be
in the state of short while right
[Music]
you couldn't drive any farther without
some sleep cops are no cops I knew I had
to hit the hay and hit it hard I was
dead tired
[Music]
mr. Haskell
[Music]
then ask them get done
I did it you know let's do a task
[Music]
who's there it's the maid can I come in
and clean later in a half hour
[Music]
there was no time to lose
every minute I had to be Charles Haskell
was dangerous not have to be Charles
Hesco until I got to some city where I
could leave the car and be swallowed up
[Music]
that meant driving the car as far as San
Bernardino maybe even to Los Angeles in
a little town I might be noticed but in
a city I should be safe enough then
after I ditched the car I could go on to
sue but those five minutes at the state
line made me realize it might be a good
idea to find out a little bit about mr.
hascomb and if anybody asked me
questions I could give the right answers
the first thing I found out was that I
had 768 dollars this was a lot of jack
but believe me was the kind of money I'd
rather not have
[Music]
and then I found out from a letter
Haskell was carting around in his bag
and he wasn't the open hand an easygoing
bigshot who went around buying dinners
for strange hitchhikers before I got
done reading and I saw him more as a
chiseler it was written to his old man
in California the one he hadn't seen in
so many years in it Haskell posed as a
salesman of hymnals of all things it was
easy to see where Haskell expected to
raise a new stake for his book in Miami
by rooking his old man that was about
all I found out from his effects and it
was enough I told myself maybe old man
Haskell was lucky his son kicked off he
would never know it but it saved him
from taking a flyer in sacred literature
preferred
[Music]
near the airport a desert center I
pulled up for water but there was a
woman
[Music]
hey you come on if you want to ride
[Music]
how far you going how far you've gone
that took me by surprise I turned my
head to look her over
she was facing straight ahead so I
couldn't see her eyes but she was young
not more than 24 man she looked as if
she just been thrown off the crummiest
freight train in the world yet in spite
of this I got the impression of beauty
not the beauty of a movie actors mind
you or the beauty you dream about when
you're with your wife but a natural
beauty a beauty that's almost homely
because it's so real
[Music]
and suddenly she turned to face me how
far you say we're going Los Angeles La
La's good enough for me mister I was
afraid of what you say oh nothing just
thinking out loud people get in trouble
for doing that
what's your name you can call me there I
feel like you're live in Los Angeles
No
are you coming from back there needles
no oh sure Phoenix he looked just like a
Phoenix girl and the girls Phoenix that
bad the girl must have been pretty tired
because she fell asleep not 20 minutes
after she stepped into the car she lay
sprawled out with her head resting
against the front door like Haskell I
didn't like that part of a punch but I
didn't wake her up
it wasn't that this girl still worried
I've gotten over that funny feeling I
had me she looked at me which I've
looked down it's just my jangled nerves
with her eyes closed and the test has
gone out of it
she seemed honest enough
and instead of disliking her I began to
feel sorry for
poor kid probably had had a rough time
of it
why she anyway
and why was she going to Los Angeles and
where'd she come from in the first place
the only thing I knew about it was the
name
not gonna made any difference a few
hours Lauren would be in Hollywood I'd
forget where I parked the car and look
up soon this nightmare of being a dead
man would be over with his name was well
it was no business of mine where did you
leave his body where did you leave the
owner of this car you're not fooling
anyone this buggy belongs to a guy named
Haskell that's not you mister you're out
of your mind that's my name Charles
Haskell I can prove it
it's my drivers Thank You self the
trouble mr. Evan asked was wallet only
makes it worse it just so happens I rode
with Charley Haskell all the way from
Louisiana he picked me up outside of
Shreveport you wrote you heard me
then it all came back to me I'll talk
about dueling scars and scratches there
was no doubt about it
Darryl must be the woman Haskell had
mentioned she must have passed me while
I slept well
well I'm waiting my goose was cooked she
had me
that Haskell guy wasn't dead yet he
wasn't stretched out stiff and cold in
any Arizona gully he was sitting right
there in the car laughing like mad while
he haunted me well there was nothing I
could say was her
véra whatever her name was was just my
luck picking her up on the road couldn't
have been Helen or Mary or Evelyn or
Ruth it had to be the very last person I
should ever have met that's life
whichever way you turn fate sticks out a
foot to tribute
[Music]
I told her everything but she didn't
believe my story I should have saved my
breath that's the greatest cock-and-bull
story I ever heard
so we fell out of his car say who do you
think you're talking to wake listen
mister I've been around and I know a
wrong guy when I see one what'd you do
kiss him with a wrench now wait a minute
what I told you was true you see that's
why I had to do it you think I killed
him well that cops what I thought so too
yeah well maybe they still think so what
makes you so sure I'll shut up about
this
sure I'm innocent give me a break will
you it won't do me any good having you
benched the cops are no friends of mine
now if there was a reward but there
isn't Thanks don't thank me yet
I'm not through with you by a long shot
let's see that roll
is that old Haskell head no no I thought
he had more not that I know of you can
search me think I'm holding out on you
well maybe I will effect he told me he
was gonna bet $3,000 on a horse named
paradise circle on Wednesday at Santa
Anita
he was stringing you along he meant 300
maybe sure 3 bucks 300 he was a piece of
cheese a big blowhard listen mister
don't try and tell me anything about
Charlie Haskell remember I knew him
better than you did okay that you knew
he was a four-flusher that explains the
three grand bet I'm not so sure he
doesn't have that 3 grand
why should I believe you you got all the
earmarks of a cheap crook now wait a
minute
you're a cheap crook and you killed him
but - since I changed my mind and turn
you in I don't like you alright alright
don't get so I'm not gettin sore but
just remember who's boss around here
if you shut up and don't give me any
arguments you'll have nothing to worry
about but if you act wise well mister
you'll pop in the jail so fast it'll
give you the pins not alright I'll see
that you don't you know as crooked as
you look I'd hate to see a fella as
young as you wind up sniffing that
perfume that Arizona hands on freedom
murderess I'm not a murderer of course
you're not let's go knock his own head
off you fell that so I have just like I
told ya and then he made you a present
of his belongings I explained well let's
do that doesn't make a difference one
way or another I'm not a morning I liked
Haskell even less than I like you yeah I
saw what you did to him what do you mean
scratches on his wrist sure I scratched
him
and say you did so your idea was to
drive the car a little way maybe under
San Bernardino and then leave it you
weren't gonna sell it sell it do you
think I'm crazy somebody else's car see
all I want to do is leave it somewhere
and forget I ever saw it not only don't
you have any scruples you don't have any
brains I don't get you maybe it's a good
thing you met me you know got yourself
caught sure why you dope don't you know
what deserted automobile always rates an
investigation huh look the cops find a
car then they get curious they wonder
where the owner is
so all right they don't trace Haskell
they trace you I never thought of that
the only safe way to get rid of the car
is to sell it to a dealer get it
registered on our new name so you
stopped at the next door I want to get a
bottle and do some shopping before we
hit LA okay since we find a place I'll
drop you off and pick you up later
nothing doing you're coming in too from
now on you and I are like the Siamese
twins
have it your way I don't get the point
the point is I don't want you to get
lost
I'm not gonna beat it if that's what
you're afraid of I'll say you're not
well I'm gonna see that you sell this
car so you don't get caught Thanks
of course your interest wouldn't be
financial with you wouldn't want a small
percentage of the profits
well now that you insist how can I
refuse 100% will do fine I'm relieved I
thought for a moment you're gonna take
it all I don't want to be a hog a few
hours later we were in Hollywood
I was recognizing places Sue and written
apart
it struck me that far from being at the
end of the trip there was a greater
distance between Sue and me than when I
started out Pierrot wasn't kidding with
that Siamese twins crack she rented a
little apartment as mrs. Charles Haskell
when I objected to this she explained it
was an account of the car a dealer might
think something was funny if he called
in front of her using different names
[Music]
oh sweet home yeah not bad either
eh is any doubt in your mind I'll take
the bedroom yeah sure is stuffy in here
keep the 1/2 shut okay the old crow down
steer so there's a phone embed behind
this door you know how to work it
I invented it some joint one can't have
everything I'm first in a bathtub I
don't know why but I figured you would
be
boy oh boy sure feels good to be clean
again I must be 10 pounds lighter you
must be
while the general rides isn't exactly
the way you keep your schoolgirl
complexion
[Music]
I wish that guy where the sex would give
up it's my nerves forget it
have a drink
aren't you afraid I'm gonna take you up
on it I didn't want to give you a drink
it wasn't poverty why be as sorry at
Roberts he got yourself into this thing
you should be grateful I'm not turning
you in
well if I wasn't regular you'd be in the
pen this minute being photographed
fingerprinted and being pushed around by
the cops
so chera get rid of that long puss oh
he's your conscience bothering you it
isn't that's the spirit
he's dead no woman around I'll bring him
back anyway
I never could understand this worrying
about something that's over and done
with now look Vera for the last time I
didn't kill it Haskell was a sick man
maybe was dead before he fell out of the
car I don't know sure sherry died of old
age all right so it'll make you sociable
you didn't kill him
[Music]
Thanks
[Music]
we're out of liquor Roberts yeah too bad
I felt like gettin tight tonight
well I think you succeeded a mark time
he's a prima donnas corset that's good
I wanted to get tight why what have you
got to get tight about no I don't know
feel things huh
you should have my worries fired your
troubles I'd stay sober and I've got the
key to that door yeah
maybe you're right I'm always right you
know I don't like your attitude
Roberts well there's a lot of things I
don't like sure good lives like a ball
game you gotta take a swing and whatever
comes along before you wake up and find
it so ninth inning you read that song
that's such Jill Roberts oh yeah it was
bellyache making it easy and well trying
to make the bit of things maybe that
what's wrong with the whole world get
the professor people themselves out
trying to buck fate now take you for
instance you're lucky to be alive
why suppose Haskell open your door
you'll be playing a harp now think of
that you think of it I'm tired of
thinking there's plenty of people die in
this minute I would give anything to
trade places with you I know what I'm
talking about I'm not so sure at least
they know they're done for it they don't
despair but wondering if they are your
philosophy stinks pal we all know we're
gonna kick off someday it's only a
question of win but what got us on this
subject anyway we'll be discussing
politics next yeah where'd you hide the
butts on the tables sucker
we bought each other with conversation
for a couple of hours longer every five
minutes one of us was wishing we had
another bottle or a radio something to
read
then finally we were ran out of chat I
know it's only 11 o'clock but I want to
get up early and make the rounds the
used-car Lots
no worry about that we got all the time
in the world maybe you have but if you
think I want to stay cooped up in this
place any longer than I have to you're
batty
it's not a bad place babe honey for
Dame's like this in New York I wouldn't
like it if it was the Ritz
you got a mean car ought to do something
about it I'll be alright
it's what Camille said nobody you know
[Music]
wasn't that the day in the died of
consumption yeah
wouldn't it be a break for you if I did
kickoff you'd be free with all Haskell
stolen car I don't want to see anybody
die
not even me especially not you
one person died of me if you did well
that's all I need you don't like me do
you rabbit like you
I love you my favorite sport is being
kept prisoner after we sell the car you
can go to blazes for all I care but not
until then
[Music]
I'm going to bed
[Music]
good night Robertson don't try and sneak
away during the night all the doors are
locked
anyway I find you got in the morning I'm
gonna call the police
they'll pick you up don't worry I know
what I'm gonna spot well good night I
hope that portable rack isn't too
uncomfortable for you I lose any sleep
over
[Music]
[Music]
six
hello hello
[Music]
[Music]
No
not yet darling tomorrow
maybe
if this were fiction I would fall in
love with her marry her and make a
respectable woman of her well she'd make
some supreme class-a sacrifice for me
and I sue and I would fall a little over
a grave and make some crack about
there's good in all of us but Vera
unfortunately was just as rotten in the
morning and she'd been the night before
all right all right I'm coming so what
the dealers will be there all day I'll
be there all year - but it doesn't wait
that long
shut up you make it just like a husband
Wow do I write a whistle yeah sure do
but let's go let's go let's go I spent
85 bucks and two hours preparing bait
and all you can say is let's go come on
we've had to feel you as car Lots last
night down this way what do you think we
can get for this heap
I don't know plenty let me handle
everything maybe we can get $2,000 I
don't know but don't worry I'll squeeze
as much out of this guy as I can I'll
let it go cheap without a fight he might
think we're still in the car and listen
don't make any slips and call me Roberts
that'll cook us I don't need you to tell
me that you better just sit by and keep
your mouth closed
remember we're both in the soup if
anything happens I get up and drive
you're my wife Vera Haskell look after
the deals closed let's go back to that
place on Hollywood Boulevard where I saw
the fur jacket I want after the deals
closed I'm saying goodbye to you that's
right I forgot I guess I'm getting kind
of used to you
that's a habit you can start breaking
let's try this place in the middle of
block
good afternoon
what kind of poet we're interested in
selling a car if the price is right
well if it's in good mechanical
condition it should Bluebook for about
1620 take a look at this motor 1600 are
you kidding
well maybe 1850 before I let it go for
1850 I'll record collect the insurance
first
hey this motors seeing a lot of driving
while the mechanic inspected the car we
had at last when we were all worn out we
hit a compromise his price okay it's a
deal all right Kevin will sign the
papers I have the ownership papers right
here with me look Vera in the meantime
will you clean a - compartment and maybe
some stuff in it New York huh
yeah but you bought the car in Miami yep
I don't know let's see about the
insurance we can either have it transfer
to canceled what kind of insurance do
you have mr. Haskell well uh I know all
the papers there I don't see any surely
you know what type of insurance you
carry in the car your name of the
company yeah but well if you'll just
tell me the name of the company I'd be
very glad to take care of all the
details
well did you sign the paper jam not yet
well don't we're not selling the car
wait a minute miss Pascal come on
darling what's the matter
change your mind yes I'm sorry I guess I
have what Jerry let's go
he got me out of a tight spot Vera but I
still don't understand all this your
will in a minute I almost threw away a
goldmine 1850 isn't to be sneezed at
the car doesn't look for as much as I
thought we're not selling the car you
want to keep it now wait a minute very
you said yourself I wouldn't be safe
until the car was in someone else's name
I like to be free of this mess when I go
that's just it Roberts
you're not going there's a driver the
next corner pull in there we'll get a
bite to eat and I'll explain what is
this another one of your brilliant ideas
oh I think you wanna make mine a ham
sandwich and coffee and for you sir
oh I don't care the same thank you
get this better I've been pretty patient
so far I've done everything you asked me
to do but no more shut up
you've taken Haskell's money you can
have the door we get from selling the
car but you're not gonna keep me a
prisoner good thing I bought the paper
take a look at that there I'm a gnome
no yes no I won't do it yes you will you
think I'm crazy it's impossible I tell
you excuse me
blow the horn when you're through no one
could possibly get away with an act like
that be wise to me in a minute
don't be yeah you look enough like him
the same coloring in the same build
see how his clothes fit you no kidding
you almost had me fooled for a while Oh
grow up Vera don't you think a father
knows his own son and it must be other
relatives so father won't have to know
you well well he gives up the ghost he's
an old geezer and he won't pull through
and as far as other relatives are
concerned they haven't seen you in 15 or
20 years eat I'm not hungry and I won't
do it it's not as tough as it sounds
remember you've got all kinds of
disciplines car letters like I could
never get away with it it's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard the old
boy has scans Abdo look in the paper
their personal fortune assessment over
15 million he'll leave plenty I tell you
maybe it cut off his son how do we know
it's out fara I won't have anything to
do with it I think you will look Vera
I'll do anything within reason but not
that so forget it
find yourself another stooge you said
you'll be fixed for the rest of your
life is Charlie Haskell's you can take
your inheritance and go away no more
worrying about the rent don't sweat and
scheming wondering where your next meal
is coming from
think about that Robert Vera please
you're talking too loud
unless I'm splitting 5050 with you sure
why not we're both alike both born the
same guy take it easy Vera there's
people around here you don't know what
you're talking about
well wait'll we read that old man has
goes dead and you show up like you read
in New York but he was singing no
suppose he doesn't die well I know we
will
something tells me but as much as I
insisted I would have no part of her
scheme Vera was taking it for granted I
would
neither of us had our mind on the cards
as we played that night I knew her just
trying to kill time between newspaper
editions this was a death watch for Vera
maybe it was for me too don't you
realize if I'm caught I want to know
where I got the car and stuff and
they'll have me out of murder charge
yeah smart you won't get caught why not
for seven and if I'm caught don't you
realize you'll be out to 18 points that
gives me 30 how will I be out you'll be
out $1,850 we would have gotten on the
car really very it'd be an awful chump
he threw away all at dawn and dizzy long
shot let me sell a bus tomorrow well the
money it'll bring in what you've already
got a clever kid like you can run it up
in no time
and we both be in the clear I'll be in
the clear anyway maybe maybe if I got
caught I get couldn't sort you you you
mean you'd squeal well no not squeal
except everybody what you meant even if
you did tell the cops I was in on it
with you what could they do to me they
might give me the same medicine they
gave you yeah a rope
but I'm on my way I'll be doing will be
rushing it alright but I think the 1850
in lose you'd kick yourself along the
black blood get away from you
I'll take the chance one another drink
you're being a goon that's the way
people wind up behind the eight-ball
once they get a few dollars to become
greedy and one more my Caesar huh you
know that Roman general he got his from
being greedy he wasn't satisfied so the
final wind up was he took the count a
couple of days ago you didn't have a
dime
well you were so broke you couldn't pay
cash for a postage stamp now you've got
almost $700 with 1850 in the offing take
my advice don't try for more I'm tired
of this game let's have some black
jacket play solitaire yeah well if
that's the way you feel about that's the
way I feel about getting sore and
throwing things won't help much Roberts
I'm really doing you a favor
I helped you out of a jam by keeping my
mouth shut I show you how to make some
soft money and what thanks do I get
thanks
how would you rather I call the cops and
tell them you killed a man and stole it
yes you did no I didn't you know I
didn't all right then suppose I call the
cops
Pierre Anderson what do you got to be
scared of okay calling me money go ahead
and call him see if right here at least
they'll give me a square deal you want
me to call you heard me
but I'm warning you if I'm pinched us
where you were in on it I'll say that
you helped me if I fly I'll get even
with you you wouldn't dare it him yeah
and try it and see
call him yeah okay I will
information I want the number the
Hollywood Police Station okay I got it
thanks wait a minute Vera you wouldn't
do that
I'll show you take it easy now let's
talk this over this was early in the
evening and the conversation while
hectic was at least pitched low but as
the minutes passed the more obstacles to
her plan popped into my head the air got
blue each word coming from our lips
cracked like a whip I reminded her that
as Charles Haskell I didn't even know my
mother's name where I'd gone to school
the name of my best friend whether I had
an Aunt Emma or not my religion and if I
had ever owned a dog I didn't even know
what my middle initial stood for I also
pointed out that the real Haskell had a
scar on his forearm his people never saw
that scurry told me he ran away right
after putting out the kids I yeah but
his father knew he was cut it'd have to
be some kind of a market so what the old
man's dead or will be I hope by tomorrow
morning's papers anyway you can cut
yourself a little cousin yeah boy well
that kind of dough I'd let you cut my
leg off your drunken you're crazy mad
Vera turn minute if you want to but I
won't get mixed up in this besides how
do we know Hesco was such a phony
if it wasn't the man son at all maybe
just dreamed it up you won't be dreaming
when the law tests you on the shoulder
there's a cute little gas chamber
waiting for you Robertson and I hear
extradition Arizona's a cinch
hi hey stinker you leave me alone I'll
let you alone when you promise to leave
the food where's your trunk you don't
know what you're doing will you promise
all right
you hurt me I'm sorry but it's hot in
there open up a window it's not hot
don't tell me now do you do it I do I do
it here no German see ya
alright I'll open up the window get open
the door please open the door
better open the door don't use the phone
listen to me like you Robert you know
gentlemen see you hurt my hand and I'm
gonna get even with you you don't open
that door I'm gonna kick it down Vera no
don't call the cops
listen to me I'll do anything you say
better let me in
I'll break the phone
[Music]
[Music]
the world is full of skeptics I know I
won myself in the Haskell business how
many of you would believe he fell out of
the car and now after killing Vera
without really meaning to do it how many
of you would believe it wasn't
premeditated in a jury room every last
man of you would go down shouting that
she had me over a barrel and my only out
was force
the room was still
so quiet that for a while I wanted to
find suddenly gone deaf it was pure fear
of course and I was hysterical but
without making a sound
Barrow was dead and that was their
murderer
murderer what an awful word that is but
I'd become one I better not get caught
what evidence there was around the place
had to be destroyed from the looks of
things there was plenty looking around
the room at things we'd bought was like
looking into the faces of a hundred
people had seen us together and who
remembered me this was the kind of
testimony I couldn't rub out no like it
burned clothes and hide bottles for the
next five years that always be witnesses
the landlady for one she could identify
me the car dealer the waitress in the
driveway and the girl in the dress shop
and that guy in the liquor store he
could all identify me I was cooked done
for I had to get out of there while one
side remain beside a dead body
planning carefully how to avoid being
accused of killing him this time I
couldn't this time I was guilty
new it tell it I was like a guy
suffering from shock things were rolling
around in my head I couldn't make myself
think right like I think I was the guy
with a saxophone and what he was playing
it wasn't a love song anymore it was a
church
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but my problems weren't solved I had to
stay away from New York for all time
because al Roberts was listed as dead
and had to stay dead and I could never
go back to Hollywood someone might
recognize me as Haskell then too
there was sue I could never go to her
with a thing like this hanging over my
head all I could do was pray she'd be
happy
I was in Bakersfield before I read that
Vera's body was discovered that the
police were looking for a Haskell in
connection with his wife's murder isn't
that a laugh
Haskell got me into this mess and
Haskell was getting me out of it
the police were searching for a dead man
[Music]
I keep trying to forget what happened
and wonder what my life might have been
if that car of Haskell's hadn't stopped
but one thing I don't have to wonder
about I know someday a car will stop to
pick me up that I never thumbed
yes fate or some mysterious force and
put the finger on you or me for no good
reason at all
you